howcome resumes welcome back to the
fairest Kimmy I'm no universe Satan
stop dancing I ask for one thing and
that was for you to not be Satan what am
i get and you look like you're gonna
give birth to a baby Timmy calm the [ __ ]
down
it's gonna be okay a big cow we are back
the force got off did it again and
apparently I'm not allowed to use my old
save so Mary we're here again oh my god
that was a lot of blood
oh well what are you gonna do so let's
explore what new things we can find in
the game now how could we crash that in
here oh that's awesome
all right this is our new home retouches
it's gonna be amazing
say it with me amazing Oh Lizzie say it
I made that it's gotta be amazing just
go god damn it oh you son of a [ __ ]
come here I'm a 360 noscope that [ __ ]
aah what aah come on there has to be an
MLG sniper clay and try out some ham
we're here do we have anything new that
we can be look let's start off with a
temporary shelter because we need it
stupid tree just go down already
there we go this is how you chop oh did
I just murder bunny come on bunny were
you even job ah there we go
well that's one luck we'll never see
again I wanted to get sticks I swear to
god this place has no sticks
this place has less 610 Justin Bieber
I'm full on sticks that's what she said
sorry
yes that is the appropriate sound of
building [ __ ] what else would they use
really apparently I only get one leaf
now from chopping down an entire bush ah
there we go
I shout that it is done ever laughs
again save there oh it's dark now we're
gonna die let's make a Molotov because
you never know they say what are you
doing in might have stopped getting
through my how dare you Oh bird
oh my you're so majestic and cute oh you
jump let what the [ __ ] happened just
turn into a feather oh god oh god I hear
something
Lisa protects me yeah be a pear now my
God protect you every kill me just do it
there's no one here you can therefore
nothing fits your dad shut up I have
listened back off back off back off oh
this is not Lizzy shut shut shut shut
shut calm down calm down
I have Lizzy now I have Lizzy Lizzy
where I am they banned Lizzy oh my god
how do you do that holy [ __ ] there
parkour guys you know what let's try and
make her jump off the cliff that would
be amazing
alright I'm here and I'm ballin
rollerball should saw through my plan
god damn it
there you are Liz listen you son of a
[ __ ] you let me down
alright you better attract this woman I
am quite under woman as a woman as a
woman they right come here hey lady you
wanna rub back massage I goddamn it
Lizzy you suck what I thought it would
work no one likes a back massage from a
lizard come on babe give me a half fat
ha it's working it's working Lissa come
on hurry
ah this way nope
denied only if MLG scouting was here
right now I saved your life Lisi you're
welcome
oh it's my turn oh god I killed her I
didn't mean to but stab there we go leg
I miss you man how are you hey peds hi
yeah that one
ready good that's good goal sorry
let's make a fire and eat some living
okay to my gun threat you're great oh
god oh god it really brought your whole
bear and barmy they brought the army
well I have to cook Lizzie otherwise I'm
gonna die just wait for Alyssa to cook
please no no I don't know who you're
trying to it's trying to kill my my
invisible friend yeah I don't know again
don't you touch your own okay he's a
great friend of mine I don't care how
great as you have ah it looks like this
is finished
alright that's delicious alright keep
stalling them John okay I'm eating it's
everyone insane
slap Darius sorry it sorry I had to I
had to everyone is crazy you're all
[ __ ] crazy what is happening what did
they do
everyone is cray-cray
alright well she killed one of them no
she's not dead if they kill you then be
dead you please start it's not too hard
to realize what are you looking at what
are you looking at how what are you what
are you looking at you're looking at my
nips you like it you like it see he
likes it very much so what are you doing
what's your story then excuse me I'm
talking to you
well they straight up dumb now that's
great I don't know what you're doing but
I do know that leg our Lord and Savior
leg we'll have to tell who will live and
who will die
oh she's scared of leg that's the first
sign of remorse meant
that's right show all your is
sentimental leg it's not gonna save a
god he just came from a tree well leg
let him live no he [ __ ] ran off the
cliff
that's right fear the leg taste the leg
taste the leg taste it taste it like
it's your mama and you were
breastfeeding come on don't run away
from me now leg we'll have to judge
everyone there we go
leg has spoken
dan oh nice nice tatas you got there
lady
Wow you can't even compliment anyone
these days huh alright we'll have to
judge you hi
I said leg we'll have to judge you god
no ah blowing glass oh ow ow you're
hurting legs feelings there you go come
on run away run away from leg ah
fatality
it was inevitable oh my god oh my god
look at all this chocolate bars nom nom
nom nom nom nom nom nom today it's my
chic day I'm gonna eat all the chocolate
bars oh my god Becky how do you stay in
that leg leg it's stuck to me what if
what if I was leg all along oh my god it
all makes sense sorry I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm think I'm gonna give I'm just
gonna give you whoa
booty had me like Bom okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
oh what the [ __ ] Oh God [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I need to get out of here
before Martha Stewart has tried to make
love with me can i really get out I
think I found it we're dead approach I'm
laughs as soon a miracle Oh Oh
hallelujah
I think God I'm so happy right now I
just want to chop people into millions
of pieces Shannon Shannon you every time
you drunk son of a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] I
did add a little too much to drink man
ain't no problem I get Shannon it's no
excuse for your behavior
akima live a little big yeah you wanted
you wanna make it no I'm not gonna make
out with you Shannon you're a shark you
would probably eat my face off
ah come on you don't know dude yes I do
Shannon I'm trying to do you a favor
here don't make it harder for me
it's you party pooper man you used to be
cool back when you had 20,000
subscribers now look at you talking to a
shark huh
you [ __ ] me all right Shannon I'll see
you later
don't make me find you drunk again I
like the water now it's so nice look at
that it looks gorgeous oh god they found
me already
oh there's yacht let's let's head
towards it's the yacht
hopefully no sharks will kill me the
water is gorgeous now I love it I love
it a sock shot all right what do we do
whoa a bomb can be used as a weapon oh
yay
we're gonna go some shark hunting go oh
that's amazing you didn't do [ __ ] oh god
oh god the gods didn't like it I'm so
sorry go oh god oh god go go go go we
can make it if only I had two arms to do
this ah thank God it looks like we made
it we made it at 11:00 hopefully nothing
randomly kills me this time all right we
have the new axe that's awesome
tape recorder yeah I feel like the moon
that's been down lately on this series
so let's light it up a little bit oh
this is my jam you can dance all you
want bird dance for me go oh my god the
music how did the tape recorder work
underneath the water that's amazing
that can't hold it when you it maybe it
would it with it how did this happen
how's it even possible
we got to run away from me hey back back
come back here
stop it back back I will get you now
please I would 11 ah ha ha ha you're in
my journey made and made by
here we go chocolate ha that's all you
got
alright so apparently in this new update
they fix the traps so let's build this
nose trap I never actually tried him
come on I'm busy never actually built it
before it's a it should be awesome
alright the trap it's complete now how
do we make them walk into it well how
does it work
Oh God oh oh oh cool
I want to be your friend I don't jump
over the trash that Dam is she thinks
she's smart and she oh my god we're
gonna have so much bad
Ricky series me yeah but first you will
have to stand the test of leg and oh
look just look oh he's singling that
means he doesn't like you oh gosh yes
back up what the [ __ ] was that
damn leg oh you knocked her unconscious
like god dammit you're not supposed to
do that
finish her leg leg you're out of control
leg you changed this trap is the coolest
thing ever
oh my god but it's awesome high price
good afternoon SEPA sewed here if you
enjoyed watching please go ahead and
leave a like it's been a great series
and I hope you enjoyed it so far it
really asked me out a lot as always
thank you for watching and stay awesome
bros it comes to brofist